hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast lung cancer evolution and
immune escape it is presented by
Nicholas mcgrann Han PhD a senior
research associate at the cancer genome
evolution research group at University
College London I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before I
begin I'd like to remind everyone this
event is interactive and we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want any time you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box it
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have any trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the ask
a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Miranda Han I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you very
much for the introduction and I'm very
excited to tell you about some of the
work we've been doing on lung cancer
evolution and immune escape so just to
begin with my disclosures I have
received some consultants with the fees
from Achilles there are piu ticks but so
then that brings me to the actual and
start the talk and to begin with that I
thought I've just introduced one of the
concepts that really fascinates us and
this is really the focus of my lab is
the concept of heterogeneity in cancer
and this extra nurture can occur on many
different levels first of all there's
inter tumor heterogeneity in that
there's no two tumors are identical and
clearly this makes
her breasts to your being different from
a lung tumor and the histological
subtype of the tumors can be very
different but even within a single tumor
type that can be striking diversity and
this is what's giving rise to the notion
of precision medicine that based on a
person's individual tumor they might be
able to guide a specific treatment but
even within a single tumor that can also
exist diversity this is what we call
interest human ingenuity depicted here
is multiple competing or cooperating
subclones
and this diversity potentially can act
as the substrate the Darwinian team
revolution and therefore may leads to
treatment resistance and the focus of
this talk we very much from how
extensive is this diversity within
tumors and how can we use this diversity
to understand how a tumors evolved and
what is the interaction and the
relevance between this this diversity
and cancer immunity and most what I'm
going to tell you about stays in the
context of lung cancer so this is the
question of why why study lung cancer
unfortunately I think the numbers really
speak for themselves as you can see in
this plot here on the right the instance
of lung cancer really is staggeringly
high and unfortunately so is the
mortality rate there's approximately 1.4
million deaths worldwide from from lung
cancer and really the moment despite
surgery and adjuvant chemotherapy the
survival rates really are quite dismal
with five year overall survival rate
less than ten percent so even there's a
pressing needs to understand why the
survival rates so poor and to to fully
understand what might be driving this
resistance to treatment and the poor
prognosis that we observe
so most of all I'm going to tell you in
the contest the tracer X study which is
a study that's been set up to track
non-small-cell lung cancer evolution
through therapy looking dick here to
start with an early stage tumors and
explore really how do these was the
evolution of these tumors and what is
the relevance of in treating originality
so to give you a bit more background
I can show you how do we explore two
more evolution and intro tumor
heterogeneity
well the first thing we do is rather
than take a single sample of each tumor
we take multiple regions of extremer
here depicted in its diagrams these are
tumors that remove bit surgery with
curative intent then we take multiple
tumor regions and each one of these
tumor regions is they're subject to
whole exome or whole genome sequencing
we also sequence the matched germline
and using this we can therefore decide
for what are the specific somatic
mutations present within each tumor
region and how do these differ between
the tumor regions and then integrating
this information we can derive a
phylogenetic tree of how the tumors
evolved this allows us to determine what
are the early clonal mutation as those
on the trunk of the team as follows
nested tree that present in every cancer
cell and then also what are the
sub-clonal mutations as those only found
a subset of the tumor regions and also a
subset of the cancer cells within the
entire tumor so so that's so that's how
we do it so then the question is how
extensive is this heterogeneity
well what I'm showing you here is the
first 100 patients that were sequence
within the tracer X study and here every
column is one of the patients tumors and
if it's blue that is it's a clone or
mutation so by clonal I mean that we
think that this mutation is present red
these are some connotations found only
in a subset of the cancer cells and what
you can see here is the certain
patient's tumor regions we think for
certain patient for certain tumors say
have thousands of sub-clonal mutations
so on the far left you can see certain
tumors that the vast majority mutations
are sublevels found only in a subset of
the cancer cells whereas there's other
tumors where the vast majority of clonal
there's really all so here we see
differences in the in the heterogeneity
of heterogeneity itself with clear
differences between tumors and also
between lung adenocarcinomas and lung
squamous cell carcinomas this is the
simplest way of looking at heterogeneity
just in these two categories the next
question we can ask is is there they're
actually more information within a sink
well one thing we can do is we can
actually look at each mutation here and
I'm showing you here a schematic how we
can do this we look at this case with
sequence four regions we can integrate
the variant allele frequencies that we
get from the sequencing reads with a
purity employee and this allows us to
derive an estimate that cancer cell
fraction blocks as the fraction of
cancer cells that harbour that given
mutation and then as we have an estimate
each tumor region we can then cluster
these to try to obtain the actual
subclones that exist or have existed
during a tumors evolution and then
looking at the various prevalence of
these using various techniques we can
actually start to resolve their
relationship to each other ultimately to
get a phylogenetic tree and a regional
subclonal architecture so we can
actually look so if we go to the next
slides what you can actually see here's
an example here we've got four tumor
regions in each tumor region we can look
at the subclonal make up a V of the sub
lines that exist within each generation
this does you see for instance that
region 2 and region 4 they share a lot
of the same subclones whereas region 1
and region 3 are actually quite distinct
both from each other and from the other
tumor region so we can do this in one
tumor and then we can also do this
across the whole cohort now so we can
start to look at the forests of
evolutionary trees of how each tumor has
evolved and this allows us to understand
that while certain tumor regions or
certain tumors are actually fairly
simple in their evolutionary histories
others remarkably complex so this is
looking at mutation or level turns and
as I said to the first well of clonal
sub-clonal mutations we can also
consider this at the copy number level
we do this here is looking at what we
expect across chromosomes 1 to 22 if
it's a normal so we'd expect two copies
of every chromosome one maternal and one
per turn on what we actually see in
these tumors is something quite striking
so if you look here in region one rather
than two copies across the genome we see
the vast majority of the genome is
present for copies suggesting there's
been a whole genome doubling event at
some point during the tumors
evolutionary history and
because we've done the multi-region
sequencing here we can look at this one
region and we can also compare that to
the other tumor regions again we see
overall quite a similar profile but
there are also certain events that
specific to individual tumor regions
again just as copy number heterogeneity
and diversity within tumors at a copy
number level so this now we can add this
to our plot look at mutations as well as
copy number events and then we can ask
the question is this clinically relevant
does the amount diversity within a tumor
does that predict response treat nor
treatment failure and this this is
really is one of the key questions we
wanted to ask for the tracer X study and
so to do this we initially said let's do
this in the simplest way possible is
just take at the mutational level and
look at the proportion of heterogeneous
mutations and split that according to
the median when we did that was so
actually we didn't see any clear
difference in the survival curves where
once political is the medium of intra to
my head relating the mutation or level
but interestingly when we did the same
comparison at copy number level looking
copy number ith we saw quite a striking
difference in the survival curves so
those patients with very homogeneous
tumors a copy number level where all the
copy number events themselves were
homogeneous seems to do far better than
the patients where the tumors are lots
of copy number heterogeneity which to us
just that this this perhaps this
indicates that ongoing chromosomal
stability and gains of losses of
chromosomes within separates subclones
is in is very prognostic and indeed when
we look and compared copy number ith
event a static measure of how much copy
number aberrations the tumor has we see
it's the copy number
ith here that's particularly prognostic
strongly suggesting that is this ongoing
dynamic instability which really fosters
a poor outcome here for these patients
we find this is significantly
multivariate analysis as well so this
ultimately leaves the question is what
drives this heterogeneity that we're
seeing the copy number level and at the
mutational level so next we wanted to
look in a bit more depth particularly
this chromosome instability can we go
beyond simple classification
one thing we reasoned is we can actually
look at the maternal and paternal snips
that are present within across the
genome this is work primarily by Tom
Watkins in the lab so here what we
reasoned is we have we have maternal and
paternal chromosomes when we have a copy
number events we can actually see
differences in the prevalence the
maternal and paternal chromosomes and
the way we do this is we look at the
snips the single nucleotide
polymorphisms and we look at those
specifically the differ between the
maternal chromosomes
there's heterozygous snips as we call
them and here we can see in the normal
they're present at 50% because we said
got one copy from your mother and one
copy from your father but when you have
a copy number event well you see as you
see a separation of these snips because
now rather than present at 50% here you
see the paternal one is present at two
over three and the maternal is present
at one over three so these two bands
separate here in region two so here this
is actually one of the main ways that
copy number tools work to try to
decipher copy number events but if we
also have a copy number event in tumor
region 1 we can see we also see
separation of these bands and if we were
to apply a standard tool we might say to
you a region one and tumor region two
look very similar but actually now if
we're looking at the orange and blue we
can see there's a difference in because
one has a maternal gain and the other is
a paternal game it's what we can do is
we can phase these snips it's what we
say is Willis take in for region one
let's take all the snips and the upper
band it's a legal Emma's orange and all
those snips and the lower bands that
simply label them blue then we can apply
that same phasing to the second-tier
region and now we can actually
distinguish and say that these are
clearly separate events occurring in
parallel during some revolution and we
call this mirrored subclone allelic
imbalance and just to show you a bit
more depth we could actually look at
this across one patient's tumor here and
this is a particular patient where again
we see separation of the bands and here
we could label again with orange and
blue and in this case we saw actually
over 45% of the genome here looking at
chromosomes 1 to 22
we found this mirror
subclonal allelic imbalance and here in
particular highlighted here on
chromosome 14 where you can see the
orange is on top in certain regions
whereas in other regions we have the
blue on top and overall when we look
across the trace tracks cohort is 100
patients that started looking at more
depth we've seen the majority of
patients we see this mirrored subclone
allelic imbalance which again is highly
consistent which chromosomal instability
is ongoing during tumor evolution so
this suggests there's ongoing events but
are these actually important are these
actually selected for during revolution
well one thing we can look at is if we
have independent gains of oncogenes so
key cancer genes when we do this we
actually saw we've got the tumors
phylogenetic tree we saw the same genes
being amplified on different alleles on
different branches of the tumors
phylogenetic tree so this just this
convergent evolution here in terms of
the same events being selected
independently across in different sub
clones
this strongly suggests this selection
that's ongoing here because the chance
of this happening just purely the
probability is having by chance it's
incredibly slim so here let's see here
one example and we could look further
across the cohort and we see these key
amplification events actually happening
in five tumors in one case we actually
saw three independent events per cdk4
ramifications suggesting there's a
strong selection perfect pressure and
constraints here for the tumor evolution
that really needs to potentially gain
the cdk4 amplification potentially this
this this may guide treatment strategies
as well and overall we see actually this
parallel evolution which is indicative
selection in 17 of these tumors so we
think this copy number heterogeneity
really might be indicating dynamic
ongoing chromosomes for this it should
permit selection for the key events
powering out the copy number level so
next I'd like to talk a bit more about
other drivers ith and a link to this one
one that we see that that is related to
cognitive Eternity which is genome
Dublin okay so genome doublings actually
been
quite well described in cancers and
particularly in lung cancers hunts you
can use sequencing data to look for
whole genome doubling events and Logan's
disappear to occur and approximately 60
percent of tumors since is the questions
actually what what happens when you when
you double your genome this is this is
something we we started to explore a few
years ago looking actually in a
colorectal cancer cell line HTT one one
six when you look at the DNA content to
this cell line you can actually see
there's a naturally occurring population
of cells that present a greater than 4n
i tetraploid genome doubles cells so we
want to ask
okay well it's we isolate these cells
and grow these and culture and see to
these there any changes is there any
association with chromosomal instability
when you double your genome and so this
is exactly what Sally did she grew these
cells and she obtained it essentially a
family tree of GM doubles here in red
and non-gm doubled plans and blue where
we can look at the different gems of
those are compared them to the sister
non-gm doubled clones and when we looked
at these in long-term culture so we grew
the passage these almost two years in
culture we could actually see are there
any changes that accumulate over time
and here looking at the non gene and
doubled clones so what I'm showing you
here is passage 5 through 275 again got
chromosomes here on the y-axis crimes
that there's 1 to 22 a copy number
gained is in red and a copy number loss
is in blue well you can see in these non
genome double clones it's really quite a
boring picture as certain gains that
were present in the original found the
clone ages T 1 1 6 but then these are
just remain present and they're no
additional gains and losses which is
using because the age 206 is making
segregation efforts we can see that but
they don't seem to tolerate these errors
and when we look at the genome double
clones quite a different picture emerges
so here again we're looking at passage 5
through to 75 or 75 s almost two years
in culture and here here rather than
just being those original games events
we can actually see were accumulating a
lot of loss events so that's from the
doubled
once they've double they start to lose
parts of chromosomes in particular one
thing you can see is the region of
chromosome four is lost in the end in
every clone there were sequenced and so
these are losses are occurring again
independently suspecting potentially
there's some sort of selection pressure
or fitness advantage to losing this
particular region of chromosome four so
this allows us now to compare these
clones that were grown in culture to
what we actually see at the terminus and
here what I'm showing you here on the
whites is a measure of chromosomal
instability based on the proportion of
the genome that differs from ploidy what
we can see is when we compare chromosome
instability two ploidy there's there's
two sort of there's three general
populations that the diploid tumors then
there's the Tetra flow tumors then this
is ten then there's these triploid
tumors that seem to have slightly higher
levels of this croatoans ability score
when we look at our clones over time
these genome table clones we can see
that they gradually become more unstable
and since they increase in chromosome
instability but they also drift down in
terms of ploidy so they've become more
triploid suggesting perhaps this is a
early genome doubling event and then
they become more and more unstable so
overall we can say that pants genome
doubling appears to be permissive for
the tolerance of chromosome instability
and went after of genome doubling when
there seems to be this rapid cancer
genome evolution and so this is the
questions perhaps genome doubling could
act as some sort of warning the early
impending chromosomal instability so
perhaps this is associated with poor
prognosis and when we looked at this in
colorectal cancer here in using the
Cancer Genome Atlas cohort we did see a
separation of the survival curves
between those tumors that undergone a
genome doubling event and reza hadn't in
blue and we could also validate this in
an independent cohort and quite
reassuringly now more recent data
looking in more later stage to miss the
found across pain camps and across
different cancer types here you see
again an association between genome
doubling and survival with those tumors
they've only got a hold
dumpling event appearance to patients
unfortunately too far worse and their
non doubled counterparts and when we go
back to the trace Rex data in the lung
data this also fits with when we see a
genome doubling event HIPAA ticked in
lung adenocarcinoma we see an increase
in heterogeneity both at the mutational
level in critically also at the copy
number level so we think the screen
absorbing meant is perhaps a critical
event permits accelerated cancer genome
evolution and we do see this frequently
and often there's a clonal event in lung
cancer evolution so the focus our focus
so far on copy number events crumbs on
civility and genome doubling and finally
I like to also consider some of the
mutation events and what drives the
later events strange in revolution here
one thing we can look at is we can look
at the different mutation types that
exists so ultimately if we're just
looking at single base substitutions and
there's six different types we can
consider because there's four different
nucleotide substitution times these can
change it to three others that means
there's twelve
but in general we can't necessarily tell
what strand of DNA at Curzon's this
reduces down to six substitution types
to pick serious six different colors and
then different prevalence of this
substitution types can give us hints as
to what's caused the mutation quite well
established here is actually that
smoking associated with c2a
transversions which in this plot here is
depicted as this gray part of the pie
and when we look to this we looks a few
years ago actually in patients and we
look to see a patient 11 was a very
heavy smoker the smoker packet and half
the cigarettes today for over 30 years
we saw lots of these seat a
transversions which made sense to us
because patient and smoked or not
patient one on the other hand was named
smoke and we still slightly fewer seat a
transversions the patient three year was
a never smoked we saw even fewer so this
makes sense and indeed this we're just
confirming what had already been seen in
the literature but with the
multi-regional sequencing as that choice
demonstrates we can also start to look
at the tumors phylogenetic tree this
allows us to say do we see differences
between the early events those on the
trunk do we see any difference between
those and the later events those on the
branches and here
we looked impatient eight are the early
mutations we saw lots of c2a
transversions this patient was an
ex-smoker this suggests these mutations
happen while the patient was smoking
indeed when we looked at the later
mutations we saw far fewer CTE
transversion as this is what we
intuitively expected because this
patient and stop smoking so we could
look overall in this cohort of
ex-smokers and current smokers because
all the early mutations were dominated
by seat age runs versions so even in the
ex mochas most early mutations are
caused potentially by smoking and then
we could also look at the later
mutations and in this case we saw that
in the ex smokers who expected a
reduction the CTA transversions
but interestingly in the current smokers
we also saw a reduction in seat a
transversions and these tumors despite
the continuous mutagenic insults of
tobacco smoke it seems that the
proportion of mutations caused by
smoking was going down this just perhaps
there's an additional mutational process
taking over here in these tumors and
indeed here we saw an increase of C 2 GN
c 2 t mutations but what's actually
causing this increase well here what we
do this will rather than look at just
this 6 substitution time so we can
actually consider the new per side
either side of the mutated base so here
rather than just 1 we can consider 16
different types of c2a transversions and
we can do this look now at each of the 3
substitution times though we're really
changing in when we do that I mean it's
40 different prostitution
let's just go down 48 different
substitution types and here when we now
look at the early mutations we can
consider these 48 types and we can see
that the early ones here again this is a
patient there was an ex-smoker we see
the early paid early mutations were
dominated by these gray bars and
relatively fat across is 16 different
types of C mutations but then when we
look to the Leighton you take to record
striking difference you see the
mutations here particularly at TPC sites
so we asked what's actually causing
those mutations well this profile of
mutations is very similar to those
caused by a phobic an enzyme involved in
innate immunity particular epoch 3p so
these tpc mutations we think of caused
by potentially afflict the 3b enzyme
becomes active and we take this DNA in
particular to mute a single strand of
DNA so here what we think is the early
mutations are caused by smoking and then
while they still cause late mutations
the current smokers alphabet often takes
over as a dominant mutation or forst's
this suggests we're getting a difference
mutational processes over time but we
can also look in space and this in one
tumor here we had regions from a
squamous cell carcinoma in a region from
an adenocarcinoma here when we look at
again the trauma context you can see
that we see alphabet particularly in the
adenocarcinoma region but not in the
screen the cell carcinoma region so this
is just in a small cohort we could then
look across the trace rates cohort
actually we see a remarkably similar
picture with the early mutations being
dominated by tobacco smoke on the whole
this is restricted to those patients
that are current or ex-smokers where the
lated mutations are less tobacco smoke
and more signature to athletic mutations
and also other mutation or signatures
taking over suggesting that well though
of tobacco smoke causes a lot of
mutations there's often additional
processes that are ongoing during cancer
evolution in in lungs okay so this
allows us to start to build up a model
of how we think non-small-cell lung
cancers evolve so I just like to briefly
go through this so first of all I
haven't gone into detail about this week
in the certain mutations that frequently
occur early during revolution in terms
of cancer genes that mutated in
particular both subtypes here we see p53
mutations being as some of the earliest
events and then frequently we have a
genome doubling event this allows us to
also time mutations that occur before
the doubling and those occur after the
dumping event because those that occur
before will present two copies because
they will be been doubled as a result of
the gender
then we can see there's other cancer
genes that more frequently occur early
in this case we see for instance
pik3ca mutations or frequently occur
later and lung adenocarcinomas and then
we also see even little mutations these
are often deep mutations in genes
involved in DNA repair and also
chromatin modification another thing we
can also look at I think it's it's quite
interesting here is that when we look at
different signatures that occur we can
see the current smokers we see the
smoking signature both before and after
genome doubling but interesting we also
see the smoking signature in lung
adenocarcinoma both before and after
genome doubling in long term exploits
these patients many of these long-term
exposures stop smoking 15 years ago
which suggests this genome doubling
event we can place that when the patient
is still smoking so that means these
these tumors have potentially been
developing for a very long period of
time and we see this in lung
adenocarcinoma but not a lot of squamous
cell carcinoma suggesting potentially
different modes of cheem revolution here
these different subtypes
okay so for the next part of the talk
let's focus a bit more about the
interaction area cancer cell and the
immune system focus not just on the
genomics but also on how that might be
recognized by the immune system so how
do we do this well computationally what
we can look at is we can look at whether
mutations might arise - peptides they're
presented by the patient's own HLA
molecules and therefore recognized by
cd8 t-cells and these peptides
may arise from mutations that the tumor
specific least is therefore a highly
patient specific and the weight
computation we check for these what we
call the neo antigens is to check
whether the peptides that contain
mutation with these binds the patient's
own HLA molecules and we use named MHC
for this so we can predict for every
patient a set of potential near antigens
and we can exercise are these actually
important well this we initially looked
at by looking at the Cancer Genome Atlas
in lung adenocarcinoma
patience here we had 150 cases did
mutation calling widget HLA typing we
also did neon strand prediction and here
we predicted not just neon strands but
whether these were clonal or subclones
whether these were found in every cancer
cell or any less subsets that cancer
cells within the patient's tumor and you
can see here the majority of the engines
we predicted we think clone of them
every cancer cell and then we could ask
is this currently relevant so first of
all we just looked at all the other
antigens or me it split according to
high and low here by the upper quartile
versus the other quartiles we saw those
patients were the high burden seems to
do somewhat better than those with a
lower burden and we can also look at
heterogeneity here when we split
according to some measure of
heterogeneity we saw some separation of
the survival clothes but then we could
also combine these two and not gesture
near actions but clone all the antigens
so there's found in every cancer cell
yeah we found patients that a high
burden of clonal near antigens and low
levels of injury to energy seems to do
far better than those with a low level
low load a number of near actions or
high heterogeneity suggesting you need
to consider not just the number of new
items but then whether these new I'm
just as a clone or supplement this may
more effectively elicit an immune
response but this is in the context of
patients were looking at primary tumor
and they weren't necessarily received
any any therapy relating into the immune
system so he makes wanted to ask well
what about in patients that receive
immunity on okayed where these neo
antigens are thought to be particularly
important and here indeed there's
already been some work demonstrating
that patients with a high burden of near
antigens for their tumor to derive a
better clinical benefit and those
patients with a low near antigen burden
sweet this is data here that was
published very elegant a swift oriented
challenge group has published in science
so we said okay well let's apply our
computational pipeline and see if we get
same results when we did this which is
that we should be predicted a number of
neon turns per tumor and then we could
these two those were the durable
benefits and those patients with a
nonzero benefit reassuringly we saw
results that were very similar to those
that are published so those patients for
high near and sure burden seems to do
better than those with a lonely action
burden but what you can also see from
this plot is there is a number of key
outliers so patients with a high number
of prevented near ångstroms that don't
derive a benefit from the therapy
someone's asked what can we can we add
the clonality to this and does that
improve improve this association
what does think when we did this we
could see that some of these outliers
actually seem to have a very highest
subclonal bird which again fits with the
notion that not just the number of
mentions but they're finality matters
indeed when we looked at the measure of
nitrogen i th we saw a clear difference
between those the benefits and those
that didn't and overall when we added
this into the into the measure of a
prediction of whether a patient will
benefit or not we saw that improved that
survived records the separation here so
when we looked at this arrival in
melanoma patients we could also see when
we separated according to number of me
irons
we could see a separation the smaller
codes but this was again improved by
incorporating a measure of ith and
interestingly we looked in more detail
and li valence cohort published with
levi garraway
we could see again a separation and
responders and non-responders
most non-responders with a really high
level of sub-clonal mutations so these
had a very high burden but no response
so what does what can actually decipher
what's causing this high level of
hibernation burden Bertie the high
subclonal nitrogen bird so we looked at
these patients now I'm showing you again
the plots across the genome and looking
at all these sub-clonal mutations do
lots these magicians present less than
one copy some of these patients humans
and particularly you see and the middle
patient here
it's tumor super thousands of sub-clonal
mutations and initially we thought well
perhaps this is a sequencing artifact
it's just that all low burden what we
could do is again and similar to what we
did before looking at soaking signatures
we could look good
what's actually cool
recent actions we can look at the
trinucleotide context of each mutation
when we did this we can see that the
clonal mutations were caused by UV light
their signatures consistent with the UV
radiation but the sub-clonal mutations
are they can look very different and
these were other than being a sequencing
artifacts we could actually link these
to alkylating agents since this is
actually caused by the patient in its
prior treatment because they were
treated by T Missoula mines so while the
clonal early mutations are caused by UV
lights and these men motivations the
later mutations were actually caused by
the treatment itself and in these
patients though I did not benefit from
the immunotherapy this an alkylating
agent and Jesus I think raises some
questions about the impact the prior
treatment can have on inducing mutations
a war and the impact that may be then
subsequently have on subsequent there
there's certain cases it may make me
improve therapy in other cases it may
not so so finally I'm not talking I
guess the final part of my title is a
mean escaping lung cancer many of these
tumors were seen there seems to be some
interaction between the canceled immune
system indeed they do benefit from you
trip online but how do they escape the
immune system in the first place
are there any mechanism so we can
recycle here so very quickly I'd like to
go through one thing with we've been
looking at and this relates in
particular to antigen presentation so as
I said to predict near antigens what we
do is we look for whether the new
antigen that mutation containing the
peptide peptide attending mutation can
be presented by the patient's own HLA
molecules so one thing we can check is
whether the as I said to predict the new
antigen whether the peptide binds the
patient's own HLA molecule these de
chelly molecules are highly polymorphic
so that HDL a allele you have eternally
inherited are quite different from those
that are paternally inherited because
you've specific HLA is very specific
binding properties and normally you
would inherit two different copies of
actually a B and C and the maternal and
paternal and so each one will present
potentially peptides and their pioneer
antigens and so therefore we look at the
maternal allele and the peptides it
presents those will pretend to be
different from the peptides presented by
the maternal Alec so there's some
evidence that the literature that loss
of her h layer L can be beneficial for
the tumor in digs in in a study that was
looking targeting the KSG 12 near
antigen which bound to h they see a
allele they found upon relapse the
patient had lost this lace C allele
suggesting but this this could be
responsible for the relapse so we wanted
to ask is it possible to identify each
layer away from this this loss of this
neon aging a little from sequencing data
if it is possible how frequently does
that occur and then when does it occur
down to a revolution and ultimately what
is its functional impact so - why would
it be hard to determine LOH tha locust
well as I said to look further which we
need to hedges I guess position to any
of those that differ between maternal
and paternal aliens and we need coverage
of these positions and the highly
polymorphic nature of the HLA means that
the standard reference genome is not
very good because the HLA is the eat
that this given patient's tumor may be
quite different from actually referenced
so their HLA difference if you use a
reference genome then this this will be
could be very different from the actual
HLA alleles that that patient harvard's
because it's so polymorphic so then when
you align sequencing leads to the
standard each lay reference essentially
these don't align so this means that you
get very poor coverage at the HLA
gene so what we wasted was instead of
aligning to the standard reference what
we can do is we could align to the
patient specific HLA alleles
and so this is exactly what we developed
tool to do we call this tool Lola and
fur which stands for loss of
heterozygosity in human leukocyte
antigen so here we align the normal
reads as well as the tumor rhesus the
patient's specific HLA alleles and this
allows us to determine for each patient
specific HLA allele that copy but within
the tumor so just to show you an example
here we can look at one patient and we
can see in this case that the HLA a zero
one zero one and real is present in two
copies whether the other allele is
present certainly zero copies there's
loss of an HLA annual so we've got a
tool now that we can work out copy
number of HLA alleles and then we can
ask how prevalent is this and we
actually see this map there's an escape
in London or we could go back to the
traceroute study and ask this exact
question and they're looking at the 100
cohort we actually saw strikingly
there's a yellow age there's a immune
escape mechanism by coding 40 percent of
the samples this is deeply striking if
we consider the mutations single point
mutations today actually instantly we
see happening less Senecas an
interesting we also saw this as
differences between lung adeno and lung
squamous cell carcinoma with lung
squamous cell carcinomas which generally
Harbor more mutations now heavier
smokers seem to have a enrichment for
this LOH event so we could mix us will
win Wenders and celebrate events
occurred to entomb revolution is this an
early event on a trunk of the tumors
phylogenetic tree or is this a later
event on the branches that you must
follow genetic tree and here what I'm
showing you is that the different trees
and able to see we sometimes see on the
trunk however predominantly we actually
see it as a branched event occurring in
a subset of accounts of cells and a
subset of the tumor regions in this case
we could also see evidence of parallel
evolution occurring independently
multiple times drain stream revolution
against a strong selection pressure here
for it and consistent that when we
looked impaired biopsies where we had
primary tumor as well as metastasis we
saw actually
there seems to be some enrichment for
this LOH event to occur in the
metastatic samples compared to the
primary tumors when it was subclonal in
nature finally we could ask what is the
functional impact of this HLA LOH event
is it actually important well given that
it's selected we'd assume it is but what
I actually happens
well we predicted that losing an H layer
though may diminish the capacity
presenting the ion streams so if you've
lost this H Lane ill these neo options
may no longer be recognized by the t
cell as firmly because they're not
actually being presented anymore so
therefore we predict perhaps if you have
more if you have an HLA event you might
get more mutations because these are now
silent and the tumor can that can under
cd8 t-cells the immune system can no
longer see them so to look at this we
compared sister subclones
that evolved from the same to send to
see whether when we have the HLA event
in one cell clone it's not present and
the other software do we see more
mutations where there's an H layer and
present when we did this we saw actually
very clear trend for more mutations in
the clones with the LOH event compared
to their sisters off loans without and
we can also see this separately in lung
adeno and lung squamous cell carcinoma
and then also one interesting thing we
could also see is when we predict these
near entrance whether they bind to the
lost or the kept allele we saw a
tendency for these particular subclone
on the ironists to be binding to the
lost applet and no longer present status
in these are no longer potential in the
origins and overall when we looked
across the cohort we could predict how
many of these neo engines that were
predicted a potentially new rule and
give me no antigens because of this LOH
event we can see in certain patients
tumors in one patient particular spouse
and me antigens that we predicted were
no longer potentially being being
presented this with represent over 90%
of the predict to the antigens mean this
is something we need to take into
account we're trying to design vaccines
therapies they're exploiting the
antigens and finally we could also look
at the immune micro environment tumors
with an l a-- h al h event and here we
could see look for stapling of PDL one
so immune checkpoint
marker here
and what we could see here is when we
had a clonal loh event so far
greatest staining of peat for PDR the
one on the immune cells as was tumor
cells suggesting potentially this
elevator event is clearly associated
with an active immune micro environment
whether this it because there for a
response or not to run or whether you're
you're seeing the LOH events leading to
somehow immune infiltration as well
we're not entirely clear you just seem
potentially this is the case that you
have an act to a meeting right then you
get selection for age lay LOH and those
are the cells and survive and we could
also look at RNA seek data for this and
subsets to calculate a meaningful trip
measures and here again we could see
that when we see an association
particularly lung adenocarcinoma in this
case when we have h lay LH we see a more
active in the environment so that leads
me to conclude what I hope I've shown
you today is that we think tumor
heterogeneity is widespread in early
stage non-small Sun Lanka so we see this
but with the new traditional level and
also the copy another and we think this
copy number Hannity indicates dynamic
chromosomal instability and it's the
copy number and not the mutation I had
strategy interestingly that is
associated with reduced relapse free
survival time and in addition one thing
we see very frequently in these tumors
is a whole genome doubling event we see
this is associated with introduce
reading we think this may facilitate
cancer genome evolution and finally
after the doubling event one thing we
will see is alphabet mediation
mutagenesis it enzyme involved in innate
immunity appears to be mutating the the
cancer cells themselves and the house
facilitates also branched tumor
evolution software expansions and
finally we also see in this relation to
the immune system that close on the
Andersons appear to hold prognostic
relevance
both in the context of patients treated
with I mean check location even of those
that haven't been treated and we also
see the potential mechanism of mean
escapers particularly pervasive here is
loss of your h lailatul so you no longer
present potential meal antigens
so that leads me to thank everyone
that's been involved in this work this
is really team science and choice right
so he led by Charles Swanson and also
set up by Mary M Jamal and Johnny and
the whole host of people have been
involved in this work particular Rachael
Rosenthal father the neon certain age
late loss and then that everyone else
also that I'm afraid of neglected this
member to enter this talk
thank you dr. Miranda Han for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button our speaker will follow up
with your questions via email let's get
started our first question is do you
think intro to more heterogeneity at
mutational level is not important so
what I'd say in response that I think ok
we see that copy number eternity is
important as a prognosis but I wouldn't
I wouldn't say that's just the
mutational level head Jannetty isn't
it's important I think we probably need
to develop more sophisticated measures
of hexa- the mutational level and D we
do see the number of clonal mentions
seems to be prognostic so I think I
think there's plenty more work to be
done in that field next one is do
subclonal drivers exist so this is I
guess there's something I didn't focus
on too much during the talk is whether
or not there's software expansions
what's what's driving those and an
overall if we look at the most known
drivers this is tend to be closed all
other events so then Lisa's the question
but what about the later events I think
again this is this is an area that as we
get more data will get better at
answering these these questions but I
think I think they're often probably are
clear drivers of later expansions and
sometimes we can annotate these then we
can tell what these are but
many cases we don't yet know what's
what's causing that they later events
train to revolution thank you time for
one more question
how many tumor regions sorry how many
tumor regions do you need to sample to
fully capture the extent of
heterogeneity in a tumor I think that's
a pretty tricky question hopefully to
know to fully grasp the extent of petrol
engine in their team and I think
ultimately every every cell within a
tumor will be be different from every
other cell so I think we could go into
as detailed it's possible but then the
question really is what is functional
and what is so what's important
originating and what isn't and and there
I think it unfortunately again it's a
kept case that probably varies from
tumor to tumor some tumors there's more
very important heterogeneity and other
tumors that they actually and most
important everyone's probably get cut a
bit on so again I think it's probably a
question is as we start to amass more
data and start to understand these
tumors we might be able to start to get
a idea of the evolutionary rulebook of
what events are very important early and
what events are important later and
really how deep do we need to go thank
you I would like to once again thank dr.
mcgrann Han for his presentation I would
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through January 11
2019 you will receive an email from
laberd's letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event
that is all for now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again